I suppose now because of your body of
work you know people say Jane Fonda they
think you know we need to say the
December birthday of course it's the
winter solstice
it's December 21st and you will be I'll
be 80 yeah
[Applause]
much less be working at my age I'm
working a lot yeah big race and fracking
Raiders for older women with
and recently you were just reunited with
Robert Redford also on Netflix and it's
hot you have to be careful how you say
it Parcells
and artisans and I don't do they only
intested that title
[Music]
oh my god were you when you first worked
with Robert Redford nearly 60 years ago
yes yeah what an amazing there's like
bookends of your life you know in the
beginning of our movies together we
checked into a hotel as newlyweds who
hadn't done it yet and at the end of our
careers we're making well no my career
is gonna keep going but his won't at the
end of his career movie where we're
checking into a hotel to do it for the
first no we were shooting the scene I
thought this feels familiar a Bob you
remembered all we didn't remember he's
that thing he is stopping now what he
says but he won't freeze well he should
[Laughter]
you